the european union would my life be any
different if it didn't exist would it be
better would it be worse linking our
resources and economies has helped us
preserve peace in the European Union
from us 70 years now something that had
never been achieved before would this
still have been the case if we had not
come together by pooling our resources
we invested in projects for EU citizens
regions environments cities farming and
businesses
this means infrastructure research
education and innovation and that in
turn means jobs but then again couldn't
my country take care of these things on
its own
well membership of the EU does mean
access to a market of 500 million
citizens and a common currency and at
larger market means greater business and
trade opportunities more growth more
Goods more services more choice for
consumers it also means more
opportunities to work and live in other
EU countries not to mention that we can
travel without showing a passport within
the Schengen area still we live in an
increasingly globalized world and
there's no denying that today large
powerful countries outside the EU are
also shaping our future can my country
really make its voice heard by standing
alone on the global stage
especially on important issues such as
global warming
global trade EU countries share the same
values and concerns so it makes sense to
stand by each other to participate in
shaping our common future to discuss the
next steps for the EU
what's your view make it hurt